welcome to the what's new and what's
next for storage session here at google
cloud next 21
my name is brian schwartz and i'm joined
by my colleague here dave nettleton
we're leaders in the product management
team here for storage and excited to
talk to you about the entire storage
portfolio that dave and i work on along
with our colleagues
during the session today we've broken it
up into a few different sections first
dave's gonna start with the strategy for
google cloud storage and then we're
gonna run through the updates and what's
new on a number of parts of the product
line cloud storage file persistent disk
and we'll end with some discussions
about transfer and backup archive dr as
well as include a few links to where to
find more information
with that i want to turn it over to dave
to start a discussion about the strategy
uh thanks brian um so just at a very
high level i thought it'd be helpful to
go through how we think about our
strategy and the different parts of that
so you know our goal is to deliver easy
to use performant and highly available
storage for all workloads with
enterprise management controls and
insights
this really guides how we think about uh
both the portfolio of products that we
have but also the individual features
within
um so the high level you know three main
types of storage that we provide in the
cloud block object and file we'll spend
a little bit more time on each of these
these cover both cloud native and more
traditional enterprise use cases
together with those we have
capabilities for data transfer and data
protection which are
very important services that come hand
in hand often with with storage
and as well as what we deliver
in terms of first party products from
google
we're very big believers in having an
open ecosystem of partners here to give
customers a
a range of choices uh um for their
workloads as they bring them to the
cloud two big categories there would be
in file and data protection for file we
partner closely with netapp uh dell emc
and uh ddn and for backup and dr
commvault and veeam are two of the
partners who were amongst others we
worked with uh very very closely
um so let me dive in a little bit on
some of the great enhancements that
we've had in the products
recently so starting with our object
storage product uh cloud storage
um so one of the great features in cloud
storage our object storage product is
the notion of dual regional storage
um and what this does is uh it lets you
manage data across two regions so
without this product um you need to you
know put a bucket in each of two regions
uh each of those buckets would be have a
different name um you'd have to
separately deal with managing and
copying data from one bucket to the
other
um if you had to deal with a disaster or
you wanted to redirect traffic to read
from one bucket or the other you have to
deal with failover and fail back
of those uh storage buckets
with that with dual regional uh dual
regional storage um
we provide a product that gives just a
single bucket that spans those two
regions so resources in each of those
regions or indeed in other regions can
read data from that bucket and we will
manage behind the scenes the data
placement
and we you know we provide a single name
space that you can read and write to so
it's active active
uh
from a read and write perspective
we provide strong consistency over that
metadata
of the bucket and then in the background
we move the data and replicate the data
between the two regions in the event of
a failure a failure in one of the
regions uh the application won't notice
it continue to read the metadata um
that's consistent across these two
regions giving immediate um
failover to
any uh
any activity that's happening in the uh
in the other region
um one of the uh uh
big enhancements that we are
announcing is that we're gonna allow not
just fixed name pairs which is what we
have today we currently have a pair of
regions in asia a pair of regions in the
us and a pair of regions in europe um
we're going to allow customers to
specify the
particular regions that they want to
create a custom dual region across this
is very powerful being able to pair
together a couple of regions and provide
a single bucket that spans those two
regions together with that we also want
to
deliver a capability to give stronger
guarantees around the recovery point
objective so we call this turbo
replication where we'll give a an sla
of uh the data that is written on one
side will be uh replicated to the other
side within uh 15 minutes and so we'll
provide an sla back uh replication um
for that for the data in these dual
regional buckets very excited about this
in uh in helping customers better
support their uh business continuity
needs and also managing their data
across multiple regions
as well as that feature um uh some other
enhancements from uh cloud storage that
have
happened recently uh so multi-part
uploads this has been a very common uh
feature asked from customers who are
looking to
use um
to make it easy to bring a large objects
to the cloud and construct them in parts
and
finalize them in the clouds this has
been a very popular programmability
feature
and then a category the next three all
around uh security so security is
something we take very uh very seriously
we work a lot with customers around
their security needs um so we want to
make sure that we support the uh the
various workloads that they have here um
through assured workloads uh through uh
providing tags uh bucket level tags um
that let customers reason about uh their
their data through uh iam policies um
and support um
you know certifications like finra with
capabilities like bucket lock that let
customers lock a bucket for an extended
duration of time and then another
enhancement that we
announced earlier in this year it's
relatively small but actually very
powerful is um with google cloud storage
we offer four classes of storage from
hot all the way down to uh archive and
we let customers uh you know tier
between that data for managing cost it
doesn't actually that all storage
classes have the same api and the same
fast access to data so even the archive
tier is online and instantly available
and customers want to tier between those
storage classes for cost purposes um
with uh a custom time stamp as part of
the metadata customers can now use that
uh a measure of time to help them make
decisions about when to tear data so a
powerful capability
moving on from uh our object storage and
cloud storage over to file storage um
both from filestar our first party
product and also with partners
um so file storage is a you know it's a
huge use case for our customers
particularly customers coming from uh on
premises where they have built and uh
rich and sophisticated workloads uh
workflows around uh enterprise file
offerings whether that's
you know just as traditional file shares
or as uh directories where they're
putting shared executables as part of
workflows um build pipelines etc
um so customers are looking as they lift
and shift to the cloud to have a a very
powerful set of file capabilities
to date we've had a file store product
um that's uh
both a basic and a high scale and these
have been zonal products and we're
really pleased to announce uh that we've
launched file filestar enterprise
uh which is a regional service so it'll
survive a zone failure so we replicate
data across multiple zones uh so
customers don't need to worry about that
they have a highly available regional
service backed with a four nines uh sla
and then we're also making sure that
this is then well integrated with all of
the other enterprise features that
customers expect in the cloud whether
that's stackdriver for logging uh or uh
rich or our security features like vpc
service controls vpn um interconnect
to help customers set up the appropriate
security perimeter around their
infrastructure and have their file
product be uh part of that and we also
want to make sure you know this is
available through our console cli nice
and easy to use and then in particular
with gke to help make i
make it easy to
provision and get
file resources there
providing the csi driver support to
simplify that
so as well as file store enterprise some
other enhancements for file
that we've announced recently um is you
know backups for file store basic so
file store basic is our zonal product
and we brought delivered backups for
that
file store high scale is our
high performance uh scale of uh file
store which lets customers scale to you
know
many tens of 200 terabytes of uh scale
at much higher performance and then as
well as what we've been doing uh first
party with filestar lots of enhancements
with through our partners in particular
with uh netapp uh and dell and we're
getting a lot of customers having a lot
of success with um some of the um
workloads that they're bringing to the
cloud with things like um smb workloads
for windows um or media rendering and
genomics
and with that i'll hand back over to
brian to tell
tell you all a little bit about
persistent disk
thanks dave so persistent disk is the
block storage offering uh here in google
cloud it's often used with the compute
engine vms uh it's probably the most
common use case but it's also used quite
a bit with kubernetes engine gke for
container workloads and it's also used
with cloud sql for the managed database
offering so pretty popular offering a
bunch of different use cases one of the
new great features
that we introduced recently is a new
class of performance extreme persistent
disk and it's really targeted at the
highest performing workloads in your
data center
particularly high-end databases sap hana
being an absolutely classic example of
this
in addition to great performance
another great feature it has is the
ability to independently scale capacity
and performance so you can really tune
you know the the the cost and
performance and capacity to really get
the best tco for your environment just
in the persistent disk volumes itself
it also includes easy to use snapshots
which can be used for like cloning use
cases so you could refresh test and dev
environments
and workflows similar to that
and also you can attach persistent disk
volumes to any size vm so again it's
another
capability of flexibility so you can
really use the google cloud
infrastructure to tune um you know the
the capabilities of the infrastructure
to exactly what you need so you don't
pay for you know maybe a really large vm
just because you need really high
performance storage so again just trying
to give you all that flexibility
dave mentioned security uh you know kind
of exists kind of throughout our
portfolio another classic example is
here with persistent disc is the ability
to have of course at rest encryption and
encryption and transit and lots of
flexibility in terms of how you manage
the keys with uh you know customer
managed keys or customer supplied keys
and another thing we're really excited
about is you know these constant
investments we make in the resiliency of
our system and extreme persistent disk
has a six nines durability which is a
you know
a measure of how durable the storage is
you know it's really important that we
invest in making these things available
and durable for you
there's a number of other enhancements
that we've had for persistent disk
that
expand beyond extreme
pd and the first one uh is probably a
tie off to what i just talked about
about durability we have a nice public
blog posting we've done and inclusion
and some more documentation for pd
uh about the really leading durability
guarantees that we have included in our
services
another service that we added earlier in
the year was balance pd it's an ssd
class storage so it gives you good
performance not as good as extreme pd
but at a much lower price point
and it's a really good offering for a
lot of i'll say general purpose
workloads in the cloud people use them
for boot disks
for test and dev databases there's lots
of reasons why these things are
interesting and it really gives you
great iops at uh you know at a lower
price point
also with balance pd is we have
something we refer to as regional pd
which essentially is synchronous
replication across the zones in a given
region uh this is a differentiated
capability for google cloud uh super
powerful and important for those of you
who basically need to protect against
zone failures um and essentially you're
getting synchronous you know rights
across multiple regions uh used quite a
bit with the cloud sql offering today to
provide the highest levels of you know
kind of availability for some of your
important databases
and of course along the same lines uh
increasingly investing in apis to be
able to deliver application consistent
snapshots uh which will really speed the
recovery time if you need to you know
reinstantiate a database from a snapshot
another small part of the block storage
product line here is our local ssd
offering and you can think about this as
a counterpoint to persistent disk that's
really targeted at ephemeral or cache
workloads so locally attached to the vm
um you know very high performance you
know very high iops very low latency
really targeted at these caching
workloads in memory databases where you
need the absolute highest level of
performance but you don't need the
persistence and you know durability and
the enterprise features that we have in
persistent disk so again a nice uh
addition to the product line earlier
this year was the support for nine
terabyte local ssds and again like i
mentioned earlier the ability to attach
these uh to many sizes and shapes of vm
so you can really again tune performance
with cpu you know memory and storage
performance all being targeted exactly
what you need for your workload
and with that i would like to turn it
back over to dave to talk about data
transfer
uh thanks brian uh yeah so for data
transfer there's two major products uh
in uh in the portfolio that we have here
uh the transfer appliance and the
transfer service so starting out with uh
transfer appliance one exciting uh
enhancement that we've had um is to
allow this to be available uh to
customers in what we call a connected
mode uh so today we've had an appliance
that um
ships to a customer's uh premises uh
either for example to move large amounts
of data from a data center that they're
migrating to the cloud or increasingly
we're seeing for uh capture the edge use
cases where um for aiml workloads a lot
of data capture that might happen in the
field you want to gather a lot of that
data and then uh bring it uh bring it to
the cloud so we've had a transfer
appliance um
to allow customers to capture that data
and ship it to the cloud recently we
just announced that we'll actually allow
this to operate in a connected mode so
you can actually
drop data onto the appliance and then
over a network connection it will move
the data
to the cloud on your behalf via that
connection uh so excited to see some of
the use cases our customers will put
this uh this too um as well as the
appliance a lot of enhancements in the
transfer service recently um you know
several here that i'm out that i'll
highlight
um uh you know first of all the
transfer service api so um
giving uh programmability control over
transfers we'll think will help
customers much better integrate this
into their various workflows
agent pools is a capability we've added
to the agent um that is part of transfer
service for on-premises so this is
something that is then is deployed into
a computer resource and manages the uh
transfer um with agent pools um we're
now uh enabling uh the
um those resources to be better managed
across multiple uh transfer jobs and
over a shared uh resource like uh a
network link so giving much more
flexibility control over
uh transfer and then you know most most
sources and sinks for their service
we've added support for azure data lake
v2 and for the appliance um we're adding
more locations with uh london being one
that's uh recently
announced um and with that i'll head
back to brian
thanks steve uh for the last content
section i want to talk about backup
archive and dr and it's a really
important area to make sure that you're
protecting your data um in all the
different places it exists in google
cloud one of the new offerings that we
just announced in september of 21 is a
new offering focused on containers uh
google cloud gk backup and what we've
seen is uh increasing the number of
customers running stateful workloads
inside of containers including you know
very traditional databases
and as a result of that we've been
working on essentially a new service
offering that's targeted at protecting
the data inside these stateful
containers
it has a nice orchestration built into
it that essentially allows you to take
regular pd snapshots to protect the data
inside these stateful containers and it
gives you pretty flexible recovery
options to recover you know individual
you know containers as well as full
clusters both in the normal you know
region where it was running as well as
potentially for a dr use case to
reinstantiate it inside of another
region
uh there is flexibility to basically
manage you know your backup policies
scheduling recurring you know snapshots
as well as setting the retention cycles
on how long you you want to keep these
snapshots around
and as gke and containers continues to
be used for more important you know very
traditional enterprise class workloads
it's important to have offerings like
this that essentially help you meet
compliance requirements so you can
create backups for the data for inside
these containers
and we also have the ability to pre and
post hooks so you can also get
application consistent snapshots
um across the rest of our backup and
archive portfolio there's a number of
other things that have been going on in
particular last year and at the end of
2020 we acquired actifio and it's the
real centerpiece of our first party
backup investments going forward
actifio was a google cloud partner and
had an offering called actifio go in the
marketplace and we've been working on
making that offering more native inside
of google cloud to really simplify the
deployment of this service you know
integrated billing and of course it
leverages all the great technology
actifio had as it came into google
around incremental forevers uh in terms
of speeding up the the backups after the
first one it's really targeted again at
these mission critical databases you
know sap hana oracle mysql etc
and it's really um
you know
important for us to continue to invest
in this particularly about making it a
first class service that'll be more
natively integrated into some of the
higher level managed services as we go
on
uh to round out this i wanted to briefly
mention some of the partners just like
dave did for a file there's a number of
data protection partners we work with
two of them who've done some recent
enhancements to the offerings to support
google cloud or veeam and commvault so
veeam v11 us which is often used on-prem
now supports google cloud storage as a
backup target so you can really think
about a tape replacement use case you
know i like to tell people one of the
hidden gems of gcs is some of the
cheaper tiers of storage have very low
latency in terms of access you can
really uh use these cheaper tiers to you
know protect your data and and have
compliance but if you ever need to get
it back you don't need to wait you know
hours or days to do restores
um and also there's a new veeam for uh
backup for google v2 that just got
released on the marketplace and it uh
also supports the archive class tiering
which again will reduce the cost for
long-term retention
uh and lastly commvault
has done a great job they're a member of
our marketplace recently came onto the
marketplace and has some great
capabilities obviously well known for
vmware backups and have done some nice
integration with google cloud vmware
engine so again uh an exciting new
partnership we're excited to work with
these partners as well as others and to
provide a wide array of backup archive
and dr solutions both from google and
from our partner ecosystem
so to round out the session i just
wanted to talk a little bit about where
to learn more information
and there's a couple other sessions here
at google cloud next that i think if
you're interested in this section uh
would be useful to look at there's a
more specific session that goes a little
bit deeper into file store enterprise
which is something
dave mentioned there's a wider aha and
availability section that talks about a
number of capabilities as well as some
customer sessions sprinkled in
throughout so really hope you get value
out of these uh included a number of
links to where to find best practices
and additional technical documentation
as well as some of the training and
certification links on how to get more
training and get certified and one of
the things that i was excited to see is
that last year the google cloud
professional cloud architect was the
highest paying certification um so great
you know kind of career option for
people to invest in themselves and we're
excited hopefully this session was a
good overview of all the thing that is
what's new with google cloud storage
enjoy the rest of the event and we'll
see you again soon thank you
you